hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
we're starting off with a game
called ode to moon
ode to a moon a moon not old the moon
oh do a moon i don't know what it's
about like most of these horror games
but it seemed really stylized what i
love about games is that
those that present themselves really
nicely in terms of their style and their
way of storytelling like what they are
and and all of the
initial documentation seemed to be
pretty cool the screenshots they had
oh it's beautiful oh to moon
i'm sure this won't turn dark and
sinister a game by color fiction i don't
know of color fiction's
any other games but i'm sure this will
be good with music by hello meteor
nice
manhattan you say 1986 you say
october you say what day in october oh
it's been pouring all night 12 a.m oh
i need to unpack later still midnight oh
cool i should quit at some point yeah
yeah
yeah eventually not right now though oh
you have a laptop in 1986.
notes from yesterday's meeting take 425
train to ashfield
document the eclipse from a scenic
vantage point the old far view castle
might be a good spot
interview first selectmen about the
history behind ashfield's ode to a moon
festival
and this year's concurrence with the
eclipse
all right oh oh
oh boy so what are we doing exactly and
why is my eyeballs all
vcr like everything half boxed and there
you are
so you unbox the booze first
oh i'm sorry
what this minimal bathroom is minimally
functional
um i have a question about what just
happened glad i watched these before
leaving leaving when i didn't leave
anywhere
i just went to the bathroom nope ladies
i am there's no time for a nap love
having a view and tons of sun last place
was a dungeon
oh god the door's open that wasn't open
the whole time was it
what the hell oh my god oh oh oh
hey oh god i hate that ah
this has made my skin crawl sounds like
some tryptophobia crap
i don't know why but last night i was
browsing the subreddit our tryptophobia
i
it just like it messed me up like i was
not ok
what was it what was what what
what what do you mean what was that
was there something that i missed or you
talking about the thing in the hallway
that just happened because that was
weird too
that was very weird okay cool oh i guess
we're done here whoa
great goody oh hey buds you don't want
to be in this train
the party train's over here you guys are
missing out i got like booze
i got cigarettes i'm loaded up and ready
to go you don't want to come in here
please anybody hey you guys over there
you guys wanna join me i feel very
trained to busan at the moment
oh i must be close
oh okay right
oh ashfield connecticut 9 p.m
all right well thanks for waiting for me
train here anybody else want to hop off
here
hey this is where the party's at can't
you tell
the crickets are getting at it this is
so cool because
the stylization makes me completely look
over the
the low res style of the game like like
everything's polygonal everything's like
very rectangular but it doesn't matter
to me right now when i'm
why
whoa i
wa wait i apologize hang on here a
second i was just on the train could i
get back on the train
i don't wanna be this isn't my party
guys i just feel like i made a wrong
stop somewhere
right okay those uh purple mountain
majesty over there
all right cool this is great love this
love that love this yeah all this real
good
oh
thank you glad i experienced whatever
that was here i go
nice whatever that was dust or snow or
something
real pretty real pretty great
was that train saying goodbye or was
that a car coming down this road i'm
very confused for a second gosh that was
scary
oh jesus i was frightened
oh warfare hey what's up cutie how are
you doing
how you doing is it getting dark here
wait what happened it got real dark okay
what what is it about this house that
makes it go so dark
oh what is happening what is happening
what's with the moon what does the odoo
moon mean
what do you mean home to a moon can't
see a thing huh well it's
too bad i guess it's too darn bad
oh well what can you do shucks
what was that wait okay
i guess i should be more concerned about
this ethereal force in front of me than
the voices i'm hearing to my left
and right well it's pretty in a
terrifying way
why am i just tramping through this
swamp
this seems like a bad idea where's the
hotel
uh i would like to get out of the forest
please can someone please show me away
oh there we go
good thank you for the light
very helpful i heard there was a
festival around here could someone show
me to the keg
i can do a mean keg stand if you know
what i mean means i
stand on the keg with my hands or my
feet
whatever you guys want i'll do i'll do
anything
for a drink meanwhile in the houses
around there like mommy
why is that crazy man tramping through
the woods talking about a keg
i don't know just leave him alone don't
look at him like the crazed key maniac
where's the blacksmith where's the
blacksmith
oh okay all right ah
yes this is where i wanted to be
ascending mount olympus to meet the gods
this is what i was hoping for
all right you know what i'm not gonna
question it hey up these stairs i go
i can smell some booze up here is this
where the party's at
good god what is this place
weird all right cool abandoned castle oh
that's right i was going to a castle
i remember now i was headed to this
castle to observe the moon
and the festival i've got everything i
need with me
whoa okay that's cool that's so
cool they've done so much with what they
have
this is so cool ah moon i'm just i'm
really thoroughly impressed by this
and discerned oh hi
is this my birthday cake oh moon hi
how you doing wow
that is pretty impressive
right
oh oh wait wait a minute
where'd you guys put in that keg what is
this
that's amazing and horrifying wait this
thing's coming why is that
oh why do you have a tentacle oh why
does the moon have tentacles
oh wait a minute hang on i've got more
questions about the world around me
why are rocks flapping like pieces of
cloth
oh oh oh oh you wanna oh you getting
jiggly
i'm sorry what the hell oh oh
oh god oh god this is this makes me
uncomfortable
everything about this just is really
uncomfortable it's just so
opposite to what nature should be but
it's done in such a really
well done whoa okay
okay okay all right well that's that's
bizarre
that's that's really weird it's like i'm
wandering through
in the wrong dimension and i can't
perceive it so everything is just kind
of
floating around itself that's so weird
this is one of the most surreal
experiences i've ever had
okay that's where i was okay so there's
got to be a way to go
around here i just got to find my way
through the
i'm sorry i just got to find my way
through the bizarre geometry of this
place
all right oh weird weird weird
weird it's all weird it's all weird it's
horrifying and weird
weirdly horrifying okay it's a drop off
oh it's so wrong oh it's shaking okay
we're shaking and shimmying we're
shaking now okay we're done okay good
oh my god oh my god
what the hell am i just looping back and
forth but the sky is changing i swear
i'm just going through the same place
but everything's morphing and changing
colors what i'm pardoning me
oh okay oh oh
no oh i feel bad oh
i don't feel good i don't feel good
about this am i in hell
i think i might be in hell oh i might be
in hell
oh that doesn't look good did i go the
wrong way
i think i might have gone the wrong way
no i i don't know
i might have jumped over something oh i
see
oh i see oh i see oh i see
oh yeah yeah okay yeah i'll send this
staircase
to the moon oh my god
oh my god
i've never seen anything like this ever
this is completely new i can't see
i hope i'm staying on the path uh well
there i go
okay i'm so wow
what the hell oh
well okay what up what's up oh you know
what yeah i don't
uh i changed my mind oh what is that
what is that what is that is that a face
is it a fish is it a baby
oh i don't like it
hi okay what
oh i have no idea
i have no idea but what it was lacking
in substance
it made up in style that was
so weird that was so weird
everything about that was weird but it
happened i
that's crazy so anyway moving on this is
face man
hi wow ooh boy this is faceman 3d
you you creepy this is a pac-man horror
game now there's been another pac-man
horror game actually a couple i think
be careful your flashlight attracts left
mouse button to place breadcrumb be
careful pac-man will consume the
breadcrumb if he finds them and then
they will lead him to you
oh try to find the exit good luck oh
oh god oh no oh oh
is that accurate is that actually
accurate to where i am oh no
okay at least just give me a compass so
oh oh god
what is that is that true oh oh
oh [ __ ] uh wait no i'm headed west
oh god this is wrong oh god oh no oh
i'm i'm doomed i'm okay
hi oh
uchi okay at least it's not
randomly generated okay this is wes if
i'm facing west right now
facing that way so i'm up against that
one oh no i'm in
where am i i have no idea where i am uh
i'm gonna go though
okay all i need to know okay i'm going
south
oh handy okay so there's multiple
different things
um if i had time to look at that map i
would analyze it and actually plot out
the
the course i'm use i'm usually good with
uh i'm good with directions
i need to get back to a map oh no
i just shot out a ballad oh no
was with the trail of blood okay
all right i uh i'm doomed i'm dude
oh okay rude
number one wow all right so uh
the correct path tracing from the end
looks like it's along that long
wall so i just need to get to there okay
so i was close
i just needed to take the alternate path
there
that makes sense okay i think i know the
way all right that's not good
oh it's not good okay i can still make
it
i can still make it if i go this way
okay who we who we oh [ __ ] where are you
kidding me
okay it's fine it's not gonna find me
if i don't move i'm having a tough time
reading
exactly where it's saying i am
okay this goes this way okay that's back
at the beginning
so this is the correct way to go oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh what do i do oh god oh god okay
don't run out of stamina
oh god oh no oh no don't find me
oh oh that's how close it got oh that's
not closing
okay i think it's on the other side of
this wall which means that it can't
really reach me because i don't think
that there's any solid connecting path
but what i have to do is i have to
double back
oh [ __ ] okay i have to run first of all
i have to run
okay i have to run but just because i
have to double back around the other way
come up an ulterior path
to get back up to
okay i ran out of stamina okay uh i am
not where i thought i was going
wait what the hell how did i get over
here i'm thinking that that map's lying
i don't think this map is actually built
the way it says it's built
okay yeah that's a dead end okay
okay that's a dead end okay it's a
series of dead ends over here okay those
are those two dead ends i
see okay ah okay so it is accurate
okay we're getting closer to the center
ah okay
cool center
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh i might be doomed i might be
doomed i might be doomed
oh just see on the map where it is
so he's going the way that i need to go
that's the thing
so he knows where that is i just got to
follow that path okay i'm gonna go for
it
if i just gun it now i can get around
where he is
oh i cannot i cannot i cannot
oh no no i'm going to round stamina oh
no no no like this
no no no oh well
that is really weird
i hate that oh i hate that
oh [ __ ] oh no no no no no no you didn't
see nothing
nothing nothing nothing yeah
i hate that breathing so this is the
central corridor
i need to go this way this is the way i
need to go
it's it's literally going the way that i
need to go oh hello light
why is there a light there but that's
not the way i need to go i need to go
this way
okay i think i might be home free i
might be home free
i think i'm home free no
oh no i'm wrong ah crap there's one more
hallway over from this
where did i make it oh was it this one
it might be this way
yeah that makes sense okay where is this
really pardon me
ah are you leading me to the path
i think it is wait and let's see where
is this
yes this is where i need to be okay then
this is the right path this is the path
yes this is the path okay i knew there
was one around here
okay good hey i win
take that face man
that was actually pretty good that was
well made i liked that a lot
the mechanics worked the ambiance worked
face man was terrible
i like that that was pretty good
[Music]
all right so this one's called wow
very impressive i like the trend lately
of making
retro style things but then stylizing it
very nice
be warned that this experience is not
intended for anyone suffering from heart
conditions or other health-related risks
that may be triggered by feelings of
terror matt reeves
oh presents all right okay you're hyping
this up a lot you better like deliver
cause this needs to be
all right that's pretty good i love the
style
the styles good the style is good i like
the style you got style
nemesis all right oh i like the style
okay i like that
that might be one of the best intros
i've ever seen so that's
pretty good it's pretty good but this is
just a demo it's just an alpha just a
demo if all of the budget was blown on
the title screen then i'm not gonna be
impressed but
right now i am impressed oh boy
uh-huh well
all right guess i'm in a bedroom
guess i'm real slow i guess i'm going
normal walking pace
you should get out more oh you're not my
mom what kind of desk is that what do i
do with that desk nothing here's my
fapping chair
oh weird so click to interact apparently
can i leave no why would i want to leave
i got everything i want right here
all right yeah that's the good stuff
that's what i want to see
hurts my eyes ah that really hurts my
ass why does it hurt my eyes so much
oh oh
well then that's creepy i like the
particulates floating in the light
but uh why is that a thing
so am i just supposed to find things to
interact what about pure darkness
oh very spooky
so why did i do that oh there we go what
is that
i can't read it i turned out the lights
all right i gotta find the where's that
light switch
uh oh [ __ ] um
oh there we go okay that'll help me get
to this one
last night i had a terrible nightmare i
wake up in the
strangest place it was like a
giant bouncy house city
was where lots of towers and really high
walls
his face was horribly dispersed
is okay well i had a nightmare
big whoop boo hoo
oh ho way way whoa
wow i'm sorry what happened hey hold on
a second
okay all right
[Music]
oh okay
good i guess i'll just walk right
towards the exit then nothing confusing
about this
seems fun this place is cool
i could do some backflips in here could
sprain my ankle
break my back snap my neck and twain
do whatever i want in here i don't like
that
all right cool don't ask me why i just
turned my head to kiss that block it
just seemed like something
worth kissing so that is
the most disconcerting drone i've ever
heard in my life
all right you're just gonna keep going
aren't you
okay all right hi
hey how you doing is that you namasusi
do i see something in there am i
am i crazy or am i seeing some hey is
that you all right you have fun
okay take care now i'll see you around
okay
what am i looking at there oh wow
ah this is so creepy oh my god
this might be one of the more creepy
things i've ever seen in my life or fun
cause it seems like a nice fun playhouse
i don't know how they built this section
it doesn't seem to be stacked of boxes
anymore
seems to be turning into something made
of flesh which is really
weird and disturbing to think about but
how could that be true
that that's bizarre that's probably not
what's happening
oh okay ah back yeah hey
all right whoa
well that's uh that's something all
right i have a body
that's good to know okay was there a
reason for me to come up here or is it
just to see this
cause that's a little weird can't click
on it so i guess i'll just
look at it real close okay all right
then
what's the deal what do i do i don't
know
anyway i'm going to go on hey nema susie
let's be on my way you are lovely
all right you are just lovely okay i'm
out of here
god that droning oh
whoa what the hell what the hell
oh okay it's the same place just look
very different from this direction i
guess
oh purple i love blurple
it's a good color okay that's weird
oh that's even weirder somebody cut
their foot someone needs to go get a
band-aid
should i follow the trail i don't know
if i want to but i got nothing better
to do so i'll follow the trail all right
i hope this person isn't infected with
anything because there's bad news bears
for me i'm walking barefoot here
oh wow wow
hey hey
hey oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god okay i
i could fight you i can punch the [ __ ]
out of you don't think i couldn't i
could
oh where am i going oh i can't see
anything all right this way okay this
way yeah this way it looks good
okay i'm out of i'm out of running
breath okay all right okay
so you like cutting off tootsies huh
that's a little weird but all right
where am i going
is it still behind me oh is it gone
i don't know if i should wait around and
find out okay
great i guess everything is safe and i'm
totally fine
nothing can befall me now all's good in
this world
everything is good
real good
hi um okay what am i uh i'll go back
i'll go back i'll i'll go back
hey buddy buddy listen buddy ooh you
suck oh you suck
i knew that everything was fine though i
knew it
i knew that everything was actually fine
you still there oh you're still there
all right oh i don't like you
okay all right i'm just gonna go then oh
where do i go wait where am i going
okay here all right you still there
oh yeah oh my god you're still there
okay cool great good
good to know hey good all right cool
i don't know where i'm going oh wait
[ __ ] wait uh do i have time to have time
ah i'm out of run oh i'm out of sprint
oh wait wait what is wrong oh where do i
go
i don't even know where i go i don't
even know what i'm trying to do oh where
am i going
it's all the same oh [ __ ] oh god
oh no okay all right we're gonna play
ring around the rosie how about that
hey bub oh donut oh do not like you
i do not like you okay goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
how do you know where i am okay which
way did i come from and which way am i
going i don't know
oh god what is this okay this looks
important
oh yes that's important is this actually
an exit or is this a lie
oh
[Music]
what was that wait what was that at the
bottom of the screen did you see that
[Music]
well there was a skull down there there
are nightmares yet to document a new foe
each night they are my nemesis
my nemeses oh hi everybody
1994. uh-huh okay
oh wow one one eight nine one nine two
oh five
69 14 75 18 19.
is that a thumb for a nose got your nose
uh
1 3 1 8 16 55 12.
oh god ugh that's some scary stories to
tell in the dark [ __ ] there
oh this is weird oh i don't like it
i don't like it this teaser of nemesis
was created in its entirety by matt
reeves come with me and become a part of
this dark world
witness its full creation from behind
the curtain be the first step into the
nightmare you can support me for as
little as one dollar and that matters
patreon.com matt reeves that was pretty
impressive
that was pretty impressive thank you for
playing well thank you for making it
that was really good that was that was
very good
i liked that a lot i like the style of
it i like the way the sound executed
itself
i mean the at the end of the day the
villain wasn't like that
threatening because it's the same kind
of like slow
chase that everyone experiences the
layout of the level made it seem like
very easy to get lost but i still found
the exit after a while
and i think that's got to be intentional
uh like designed to funnel you to the
exit eventually
and that's pretty cool that's hard to do
it's hard to pull off i could have
easily just been
spinning around in circles or maybe i
got lucky i don't actually know okay but
that
is three scary games thank you all so
much for joining me on this adventure
we just had banger after banger after
banger of
good scary games those were
great love those a lot so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you've
got more scary games that you want to
see in the next episode
let me know down in the comments and let
me know if you want to see more of this
right down there below thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other scary games i've got in the
description or suggested videos over
there
and as always we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you